on a dit aussi des choses un peu moins
gentilles on a dit que vous aimiez bien
enfin votre style était un peu d'allumer
des messieurs d'un certain âge c'est
vrai
en tout cas ce qui vous rapproche de
deau c'est que vous aimez les animaux
non
vous avez pas entendu gratter là alors
on a un petit cadeau pour vous puisque
vous n'avez pas encore reçu de cadeaux
voici Rocky ok attends
petit hamster je vous laisse pour non
non
parce qu'il part très très vite bon et
puis puisque c'est vos 18 ans avec une
jeune fille a droit à 18 ans à des
fleurs blanches évidemment voici un beau
bouquet je vais vous le prendre
anniversaire Vanessa et merci infiniment
d'être venu fêter ça en direct avec nous